Now, over the weekend, as Donald Trump continued,
continued to tweet, lies out of control.
President elect Joe Biden and Vice President elect
Kamala Harris address the nation for the first
time as president and vice president elect. We're
going to look at some clips. The event was almost
jarring in how different it was from what we've
become accustomed to, even though I've been saying
we can't allow crazy to be normalized. Watching
Joe Biden's speech not be riddled with insults and
lies, the way we've become accustomed to watching
Kamala Harris not insult everybody and speak in
completely hyperbolic agit trash language,
I realized how I had become desensitized to
Trump because this felt so strangely normal. Full
sentences felt unusual. First was Kamala Harris.
Take a listen. Saying voters chose unity, decency,
science and truth delivered a clear message.
You chose hope and unity,
decency, science and, yes, truth.
You chose Joe Biden as the next
president of the United States.
Joe Biden then literally came out
running when introduced by Kamala Harris,
which is a major change of pace in terms
of the energy we've seen from sluggish
down of Trump for a while now.
And then Joe Biden with a focus
on unity and his popular vote victory.
Just the people of this nation have spoken.
They've delivered us a clear victory, a
convincing victory, a victory for we the people
we've won with the most votes ever cast from
presidential ticket and the history of the nation.
Seventy four million that focus on unity
remained throughout the speech tonight.
We're seeing all over this nation, all
cities and all parts of the country, indeed,
across the world, an outpouring of joy, of hope,
renewed faith, and tomorrow bring a better day.
And I'm humbled by the trust and confidence
you placed in me. I pledge to be a president
who seeks not to divide but unify and very
importantly, Joe Biden mentioning coronavirus.
We're going to talk a lot today
about Joe Biden and coronavirus
in the battle to save our planet
by getting climate under control.
The battle to restore decency, defend democracy
and give everybody in this country a fair shot,
that's all they're asking for, a fair shot, folks.
Our work begins with getting
covered under control.
We cannot repair the economy, restore our vitality
or relish life's most precious moments, hugging
our grandchildren, our children, our birthdays,
weddings, graduations, all the moments that matter
most to us until we get it under control.
Later, I plan to get right into Joe Biden
announcing his plan for coronavirus and his
plan for coronavirus will be very different
from Donald Trump's plan and that Joe Biden's
plan will be a plan. We're going to have someone
with a plan which is so different, a task
force being assembled today by Joe Biden.
And then lastly, Joe Biden using this term.
I've been using calling this an inflection
point where we stand at an inflection point.
We have an opportunity to defeat despair,
to build a nation of prosperity and purpose.
We can do it. I know we can. I've long talked
about the battle for the soul of America.
We must restore the soul of America.
So this was the correct speech at the right time.
I've read and received many comments saying,
David, these are just platitudes. They
might sound nice compared to Trump,
but these are just platitudes. Well, this is
the time for platitudes. We will hold Biden
accountable on policy and accomplishments. He
gave the right speech for the time that it was.
And we've already got a long list of things to
talk about today from the standpoint of policy
and executive orders. We're not Joe Biden's
not waiting and we're certainly not waiting.